how's it going for us today we're back
with I am bread there's a new level cold
or is it marinus Team Fortress 2 what
what is this not gonna do anything to
that man maybe a toast but I've got
[ __ ] standards I've played enough
Team Fortress 2 to know where this is
going all right and I'm not going inside
that man it's not happening
I forgot how to play this game
apparently I'm touching his knee and
though some people are into that [ __ ]
don't look at me no no I did not ask for
this
god damn it here we go this is going
great I don't feel comfortable I don't I
don't know where this game is going with
this like this like this mm-hmm
like when toast is touching you all
right let's go
disgusting I can't believe I'm doing
this this is horrible this is this is
tow station all right all right
Oh God oh the dr6 okay all right we can
still make it maybe a little bit of
chemicals but a little bit of chemicals
has never hurt anyone
here we go ah man down toast down all
right the plan is to just jump all right
I know it sounds crazy and it might just
be
yeah boy hurry up Wow
yeah that's how it's done oh god it's
not an a-bomb no problem just approach
it gently gently careful now careful now
Oh got it Express a bump exploded man
that was pretty intense ad bomb there
okay okay yeah all right we're almost
yeah almost there to the delicious are
we gonna go inside his mouth once we
done the sandwich because I don't know
how I feel about that either all right
like I said I have standards go at it
let oh my god that was the best all
right I did it that was it that was
[ __ ] it I wanted to go inside him I
said it so many times are you kidding me
are you kidding me four minutes I waited
two months for an update every day every
day I check my calendar and I oh I'm so
furious
what is this Star Wars that better be
something that better be something
starch wash stache wash the Dutch
version of Star Wars what what what you
know what I'm a coach shooting later
that's cool enough all right Star Wars
just as I remembered it oh my god what
is going on I feel like I took some
drugs this morning considering what I'm
wearing
thank that possibility is not completely
overruled Jesus did I do my toast is six
I am NOT toast I don't know if I'm
playing a real game right now I feel
like this could be all in my head oh
okay it's happening all right all right
all right
yes give me more all right we're gonna
have to end that episode there but if
you enjoyed please leave a like check
out the rest of this playlist check out
the game check out your life do whatever
you want I don't know there's a life out
there and you gotta live it thanks for
watching always stay off
you're proud base but goddamn you suck